hey I hope you guys all watch tomorrow
night we're so excited for House Stark
Jodie Sweetin at rehearsals yesterday
making sure that there will be a full
house tonight on Dancing with the Stars
at premieres on ABC
meanwhile her competition Kim field so
that's what she's most worried about
being light on her feet one two three oh
this one never wants to eat never did
you get some content that the father
somebody lifting you and dragging you in
the way I got away to powder but she was
only kidding about not eating yesterday
i sending like three pictures secant
eating the mom of two flies back and
forth from atlanta for hers and her boys
like getting in on the action
quitsies you know - so he knows mommy's
in this place and you know he do he
thinks your wedding photos now let
Sebastian if I show him some video of
Sasha you know slipping in foil and
somebody he's like Oh mr. so much you
did that no mommy I don't think you
should do that of course we first fell
for chemist to D on the 80s sitcom the
facts of life and loved her reaction
when we played her first ever et
interview from back in 82 when she was
13
I'm very shy bully waiteth and I when
I'm just meeting somebody
I get very closed up an intimate and and
I get very shy no no it's seriously
folks say that's your close-up and into
it now 46 we kind of think she's barely
changed it's a blessing you know one
deputy and anything especially in the
entertainment industry I don't I don't
take it for granted you know Kim said
she actually fully expects some of her
facts of life friends to show up during
you know maybe please layer come on nice
come on the facts of life we're talking
about the facts of life